hemos visto estos días una pompa sin
igual en la historia reciente por la
muerte de la monarca que nos indica esto
sobre el estado de la monarquía en Reino
Unido y sobre la imagen que el país y la
institución proyectan hacia el exterior
Bueno lo primero Muchas gracias por
contar conmigo le respondo de inmediato
muestra una sintonía absoluta del pueblo
británico con consumonarquía no
solamente en lo que configuran los
territorios de Irlanda gales y Escocia
Escocia menos no pero y también de la
common Gold y también lo que está
buscando desde luego la el gobierno de
la propia casa real británica es pues
una magnificencia un protocolo y una
estructura
internacional que ubica el país en una
posición primaria cuando ha salido el
brexit no
tanto día de funeral tanto protocolo
pues pues insiste mucho en esta idea no
hay una sintonía al pueblo sin duda con
aquí ya más allá de los porcentajes de
los que le apoyan o no y desde luego la
proyección internacional está siendo muy
positiva para la causa general de la
nación de la gobernación y de la nueva
monarquía que viene y con el fin
precisamente de los 11 días de luto
comienza oficialmente La era de Carlos
III al frente de la corona británica que
retos afronta ahora al nuevo monarca
pues bastantes no piense usted O al
menos estar mi tesis que lo tiene fácil
no primero mantener Unido al país
recuérdese que en Escocia el la
estructura societaria por la
independencia
está en torno al 48 o 45 que casi ganan
el referéndum precedente no en gales
también en hay unos sentimientos
significativos menores esta Pero existe
no Por tanto la unidad de territorial
del propio Reino Unido no más allá de
los conflictos de Irlanda del Norte
porque los conocidos y obviamente no nos
meteremos en ellos no y luego tiene
también el reto de mantener unida a la
commonwald no recuérdese que sigue
siendo Carlos tercero sigue siendo rey
de Australia de Nueva Zelanda y de
Canadá no Nueva Zelanda también ya hay
voces en contra de esto y ha habido
referéndum no y luego la comangola
ahorita esta Unión de 54 países que
conforman digamos una unidad lingüística
histórica por por el Imperio que mantuvo
no Y hasta la que alcanzó su Cenit de
1916 Pues también tiene
desde luego tiene tiene ese reto no y
dos más si mi opinión no mantener el
amor a la corona que ha tenido su señora
madre ahora difunta mantener ese amor
global que no va a ser fácil Pues porque
cada vez Estas instituciones en Europa
donde yo vivo Pues estamos cuestionadas
no solamente en el Reino Unido sino en
todos los países que somos anárquicos
verdad y luego también tiene que
liderar con un post brexit que mi
opinión ha sido un error catastrófico
para el Reino Unido y que le va a
generar muchos problemas económicos y
cosas medio plazo no esto serían mi
opinión los los hitos que tiene bueno Y
si me permite usted el mismo no O sea el
mismo y Camila Parker bowls la imagen
bueno que ya la reconsiderado la
reconstruido después
de los acontecimientos por todos
conocidos con ellos y pero que también
tiene que reconstruir y mejorar su
propia imagen estos días sacamos ya
algunos errores de ira global que
tampoco le han hecho mucho bien pero en
general va bien la cosa